[Musik]
was kostet die krise mehr als eine
billion euro sorgt die bundesregierung
geldsorgen plagen aber auch städte und
kommunen letzte hoffnung lufttransport
auf frankreichs intensivstationen wird
es immer schwieriger
das militär muss viele kranke
umverteilen
hunderte tote jeden tag auch
großbritannien kämpft gegen die
infektionswelle
jetzt wendet sich die queen an ihr volk
und fordert disziplin
nachrichten nicht erst heute mit
christian sievers die welt an diesem
sonntag guten abend ihnen allen dass die
weltweite corona krise für diejenigen
heißt die jetzt um ihr leben kämpfen
oder um angehörige trauern ist kaum zu
beschreiben
die folgen für die gesellschaft kann man
beziffern wenn auch erst vorläufig und
in zahlen die so gewaltig sind dass es
schwer ist sie zu fassen
für das corona hilfsprogramm hat die
bundesregierung jetzt ausgaben und
garantien in höhe von 1.200 73
milliarden euro beschlossen
eine schwindelerregende summe wie dieser
vergleich zeigt das ist die gesamtsumme
die die bundesregierung eigentlich in
diesem jahr ausgeben wollte das neue
hilfspaket ist etwa dreieinhalb mal so
groß wie all das zusammen
heike slansky das land steht still doch
die kosten laufen davon hilfspakete
mehrausgaben mindereinnahmen und kein
ende in sicht
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen fordert jetzt sogar einen
marshall plan für europa nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg solidarität sei jetzt
das gebot der stunde
wir haben ein umfangreiches paket in der
vorbereitung was den ländern hilft die
besonders von der krise betroffen sind
das ist der esm das ist die europäische
investitionsbank das sind notfall
klausel den europäischen verträgen
das sind laufende haushaltsmittel ich
denke mal dafür brauchen wir jetzt keine
corona bonds keine europäischen anleihen
mit gemeinsamer haftung wenn es nach der
cdu spitze geht das
bundesfinanzministerium rechnet jetzt
schon mit astronomischen summen corona
soforthilfen der wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds länder und
gemeinden die sozialversicherungen und
garantien des bundes macht ein volumen
von mehr als 1,2 billionen euro
die rege ich an dass wir wirklich
darüber nachdenken dass diejenigen die
über riesige vermögen fügen verfügen bei
hohen freibeträgen für betriebsvermögen
dann auch an der finanzierung beteiligt
werden die geltenden beschränkungen
allmählich zu lockern fordern manche
experten ohne jedoch die gesundheit aufs
spiel zu setzen
jeder monat den wie die wirtschaft ruhen
lassen kostet etwa drei bis vier
des bruttoinlandsproduktes geht also um
enorme summen die wirtschaft nach der
krise mit einem konjunkturpaket zu
unterstützen erweckt bereits die
regierung gewaltige summen und längst
nicht das ende der fahnenstange
auch die finanziellen folgen werden uns
also sehr lange beschäftigen
deutschlands städte und gemeinden
schlagen bereits jetzt alarm kroner
bringt sie in not vor allem finanziell
wie thaddeus parade berichtet apostolos
tsalastras ist kämmerer von oberhausen
und blickt mit großer sorge in die
zukunft die stadt im ruhrgebiet steckt
tief in den roten zahlen schulden in
höhe von 1,9 milliarden euro erlauben
kaum noch handlungsspielraum mit der
korona krise aber bricht das wenige auch
noch weg wir werden auf alle fälle im
jahr 2020 über 50 millionen euro
verlieren bei den strukturschwachen
kommunen wird dass der genickbruch seien
nicht nur klammen kommunen wie
oberhausen brechen die einkommens und
gewerbesteuer komplett weg bundesweit
rechnen die städte mit einem defizit von
elf milliarden euro allein für dieses
jahr
wir stehen an der vordersten front beim
kampf gegen das virus
und deswegen erwarten wir die
unbegrenzte unterstützung von bund und
ländern
die zeit drängt denn deutsche städte
schleppen bereits altschulden in höhe
von 115 milliarden euro mit sich
der von bundesfinanzminister olaf scholz
jüngst vorgeschlagene altschuldenfonds
für klamme kommunen könnte durch die
krise mehr unterstützer finden
ich gehe davon aus die tür des
finanzministers ist noch offen
es entstehen neue schulden und man kann
im laufe dieses jahres denke ich dann
überlegen ob man die alten schulden und
die neu entstehenden in einem
gesamtpaket packt und einfach einen
schnitt sie damit die kommunen dauerhaft
handlungsfähig bleiben bislang hatten
besonders reiche länder den vorschlag
aus dem bundesfinanzministerium
abgelehnt
corona krise aber trifft alle egal ob
reich oder arm 500 euro prämie
steuerfrei sollen alle die pflegen in
krankenhäusern alten- und
behindertenheimen in bayern bekommen
das kündigte ministerpräsident markus
söder an rund 250.000 angestellte
könnten davon profitieren
die kosten für den freistaat rund 125
millionen euro
die bonuszahlung sei eine anerkennung
für ihren oftmals aufreibenden einsatz
in der korona krise wieder sagt
schutzmasken sind mangelware in europa
jetzt gibt es etwas nachschub der
flugzeughersteller airbus hat rund vier
millionen masken aus china nach hamburg
gebracht
ein teil wird in deutschland
medizinischen einrichtungen übergeben
andere werden nach frankreich spanien
und großbritannien verteilt es ist
bereits der dritte solche hilfsflug und
jetzt in der sendung der blick auf die
statistik hinter der sich natürlich
viele schicksale verbergen und zugleich
die frage wie wirken die einschränkungen
des täglichen lebens in deutschland
antworten jetzt von david sauer
nach erhebungen der johns hopkins
universität sind in deutschland stand 18
30 97 1351 infektionen bestätigt 1479
menschen sind in verbindung mit 19
gestorben
die dynamik der epidemie zeigt sich am
zeitraum in dem sie infizierten zahl
verdoppelt anfang märz waren ist nur
zwei tage
bundesweit sind es jetzt 9,6 das
ansteckung stampa hat also nachgelassen
aber erst wenn die verdopplung zeit
gegen 14 tage geht will die
bundesregierung ein lockern der kontakt
beschränkungen erwägen sie gelten bis
mindestens 19 april mit der aktuellen
rate gäbe ist bis dahin mehr als 270.000
infizierte mit 14 tagen verdopplung zeit
wären es rechnerisch fast 80.000 fälle
weniger
die dunkelziffer liegt nach schätzungen
bei einem vielfachen lässt sich aber nur
schwer bestimmen wie viel leid sich
hinter den zahlen von gestorbenen und
infizierten verbirgt kann man erahnen
wenn man dieser krankenschwester in
großbritannien zu hören
die sich an ihre mitbürger wendet
charlie watts sagt wir sind am boden
es ist wirklich schwierig wir versuchen
unser bestes aber wir haben immer den
eindruck wir könnten mehr machen
aber mehr geht nicht bitte haltet euch
an die neuen regeln bitte bleibt zuhause
die zahl der toten in großbritannien
steigt weiter rapide
heute abend spricht die queen zu ihrem
volk es ist abgesehen von weihnachten
erst das vierte mal in den 68 jahren
ihrer regentschaft auf schloss windsor
wurde die rede der monarchien bereits
aufgezeichnet sie hat sich hierhin
zurückgezogen aus vorsicht wegen des
virus ihr sohn prinz charles war mit
corona infiziert und wir gehen jetzt
live nach london zu diana zimmermann
diana was hat die queen heute abend für
eine botschaft die queen hält zwar eine
unübliche rede aber sie fällt natürlich
nicht aus ihrer rolle
sie wird die briten zur einigkeit und
zuversicht gemahnen
sie wird außerdem dem medizinischen
personal danken denn dieser situation
haben außerdem der palast und downing
street beschlossen dass es nicht schaden
kann wenn die queen an das
durchhaltevermögen und den
widerstandsgeist briten im zweiten
weltkrieg erinnert eigenschaften denen
sie und wir den sieg über die nazis mit
zu verdanken haben und warum hält sie
diese rede gerade jetzt
naja das ist die woche nach der eben die
todeszahlen hier sprunghaft angestiegen
sind für ostern wird mit etwa 1000 toten
am tag gerechnet der premierminister ist
immer noch corona krank und seine
regierung bekommt massive kritik für das
krisen management gleichzeitig sind die
nachrichten aus den krankenhäusern haben
es gerade gesehen dramatisch es fehlt an
personal an beatmungsgeräten zunehmend
auch an sauerstoff in der nächsten woche
werden die ressourcen her wahrscheinlich
so knapp dass ärzte dann eben
entscheiden müssen wenn sie behandeln
und wen nicht mehr in dieser situation
soll die queen die in großbritannien
natürlich das symbol für beständigkeit
und stabilität ist dafür sorgen dass den
briten die zuversicht nicht ausgeht
diana herzlichen dank
sondern und die ansprache der queen live
ab 21 uhr unserer zeit auf heute.de und
außerdem können sie sich über die zdf
heute app jederzeit informieren etwa mit
einem live blog
die mit abstand meisten bestätigten
infektionen weltweit gibt es in den usa
der präsident greift jetzt zu
drastischen maßnahmen und schickt das
militär in den kampf gegen korona
tausende soldaten sollen helfen das
virus einzudämmen
donald trump rechnet damit dass die
nächsten zwei wochen besonders hart sind
es werden schreckliche zeiten sagt er
wörtlich dann sollten wir auf die gucken
wie auch in normalen zeiten kaum zugang
zu medizinischer versorgung haben
in griechenland hat das virus ein
flüchtlingslager erwischt es wurde
komplett unter quarantäne gestellt für
mindestens zwei wochen
ein flüchtling dort hatte sich
angesteckt in dem camp in der nähe von
athen leben etwa 1800 menschen teils
unter widrigsten bedingungen
es ist bereits das zweite
flüchtlingslager das in griechenland
unter quarantäne steht bei unseren
nachbarn in frankreich wird die lage
immer schlimmer die infektionszahlen
steigen weiter an
trotz drastischer ausgangssperren zu
beginn der osterferien sind die
kontrollen deshalb noch einmal
verschärft worden so soll verhindert
werden dass die menschen aus den
metropolen aufs land oder ans meer
fahren über die situation in frankreich
berichtet thomas walde frankreichs
krankenhäuser verzeichnen einen
traurigen rekord noch nie lagen so viele
menschen auf intensivstationen wie in
diesen tagen doch zumindest in der
besonders betroffenen krisenregion
elsass gibt es ersten vorsichtigen
optimismus bei den ärzten seit 24
stunden haben wir ein zwei betten die
leer geblieben sind und die kranke unter
guten bedingungen aufnehmen könnten
[Musik]
heute ernten wir was wir vor zwei wochen
angestoßen haben wenn wir jetzt nicht
aufpassen werden wir das in zwei wochen
wieder bezahlen
die andere große krisenregion ist paris
der flughafen orly ist für kommerzielle
flugzeuge gesperrt das militär bringt an
diesem wochenende dutzende patienten in
weniger belastete teile des landes
diese zivil militärische operation ist
historisch weil es solche umstände einer
infektion noch nie gab
aufrüsten tut auch die polizei des
landes hunderttausendfach kontrolliert
sie ob sich franzosen an die
ausgangssperre halten die nur bestimmte
ausnahmen zulässt eine reise aufs land
zu beginn der osterferien gehörte nicht
dazu
in jura wir lassen kein bisschen locker
weil es darum geht menschenleben zu
retten die botschaft ist eindeutig um
die menschen zu schützen die wir lieben
muss man die ausgangssperre beachten des
ecofin eine grundsätzliche debatte wie
diese ausgangssperre beendet wird gibt
es in frankreich kaum die regierung hat
angekündigt dass sie schrittweise
aufgehoben werde
wann dort nach welchen kriterien sagt
sie bislang nicht
auch in deutschland gibt es ausgangs
begrenzungen und kontrollen das schöne
frühlingswetter zog heute viele nach
draußen
doch manchmal hieß es stoppt kontrollen
gab es etwa an der landesgrenze zu
schleswig-holstein weil ein
einreiseverbot gilt für alle die nicht
dauerhaft dort wohnen auch in bayern
wollte die polizei an vielen orten
verhindern dass städter aufs land fahren
am spitzingsee der nur etwa 60 kilometer
von münchen entfernt ist war conny
hermann spitzingsee ein beliebtes
ausflugsziel in den schlierseer bergen
noch am vergangenen wochenende war der
kleine ort voll
heute dagegen nur wenige fast
ausschließlich einheimische
spaziergänger und sportler die
vielfachen aufrufe zu hause zu bleiben
haben offensichtlich gewirkt
polizei zeigt präsenz kontrolliert ob
sich irgendwo zu viele menschen
versammeln
das ist nicht der fall doch solche
tourengeher bereiten der bergwacht
derzeit kopfzerbrechen
jeder einsatz wäre eine gefahr für die
retter sollte sich natürlich einer
dieser bergretter infizieren wäre der
ganze rettungstruppe automatischen
quarantäne gehen das heißt wir haben
leute zwölf leute weniger im
niedersächsischen rasdorf haben sich
motorradfahrer bei frühlingshaften
temperaturen an einem beliebten
bikertreff zusammengefunden aber auch
für sie gilt mindestabstand wir treffen
uns eigentlich fast jeden sonntag und
das wäre einigermaßen mitspielt und
heute haben wir von vornherein abgemacht
dass wir nur kurz hier sind nichts geht
mehr heißt es hier an der grenze
zwischen hamburg und schleswig holstein
an einem beliebten radweg schickt die
polizei heute hunderte ausflügler wieder
zurück in die hansestadt
ich finde das natürlich sehr bedauerlich
dass wir jetzt immer mehr ihr rad fahren
dürfen
andererseits anders geht es nicht wir
müssen diese maßnahmen einhalten und
auch wenn's schwer fällt die
allermeisten menschen in deutschland
haben sich heute daran gehalten
in einem fast leeren petersdom in rom
hat papst franziskus die karwoche
eröffnet in seiner predigt zum
palmsonntag rief der papst die menschen
dazu auf in der derzeitigen krise auf
gott zu vertrauen
der palmsonntag erinnert an den einzug
jesu in jerusalem vor seiner kreuzigung
die gläubigen aus aller welt konnten
online an der messe teilnehmen
so sonntagabend eine weitere woche geht
zu ende die wir so schnell nicht
vergessen werden
beklemmende nachrichten aber auch immer
wieder ihre einfälle die all das ein
bisschen erträglicher machen
philipp klein hat ein video und die
sozialen netzwerke gepostet im kampf
gegen das fernweh er zeigt wintersport
geht auch im schlafzimmer passt ganz gut
denn das wetter hat mit schnee nichts
mehr zu tun
morgen scheint überall die sonne
höchsttemperaturen 18 bis 25 grad an den
küsten 15 bis 19 grad und in den
kommenden tagen bleibt es so mit viel
sonne team 19 verabschiedet sich mit
herzlichen dank für das große interesse
von ihnen ein
der kollege claus kleber hat mehr im
heute journal um 21.45 an dieser stelle
ist morgen barbara hahlweg für sie da